Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Here, so that it
doesn't interrupt us as we get started, but just
to go through a pretty quick agenda here we'll
just go through some introductions and we'll have,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Our awesome
presentation by Nathan Stephens, and
then a lot of time for Q & A and just some open
discussion and networking amongst the group too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But I do just want
to make sure I note that it is being recorded
and the session will be shared up to
YouTube for anybody who missed it or,
if you want to go back and check it out,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Again, but for anyone
who's joining this group, for the first time,
this is a friendly and open meetup environment,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): For teams to share the
work that they're doing within their organizations
also teams from our studio to share
some of the work that we're doing,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): teach lessons learn
network with each other, but really just allow
us all to learn from each other, so thank you
all for making this a welcoming community,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And if you do ever
have suggestions or general feedback
i'll share a form at the end as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But we will have a
slideshow link for any questions that you have
during the talk so if you don't want
to be part of the recording as well,
you could also ask anonymous questions there
too, but i'll share that in just a minute,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But with that
I would love to introduce our speaker
Nathan Stephens so Nathan, will be
presenting on scaling spreadsheets with our,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Nathan, is
an enterprise architect here at RStudio
and has a background and analytic
solutions and consulting,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and
experience building data science
team architected analytic infrastructure and
also delivering innovative data products,
so that I will stop my share
Nathan and turn it over to you,
Nathan Stephens: Great thanks Rachael it's
a real honor to be doing this and appreciate
you Rachael setting this up and thanks Maria for
getting this going and even inspiration
here really appreciate the opportunity,
Nathan Stephens: Hopefully, I don't
value everyone's time I have a lot
of people on the call, and so I want
to make sure that you walk away with,
Nathan Stephens: Some information something
some new ideas something useful that you can
take with you, and if you can't i'm going
to try to entertain you to some extent,
so if there's nothing here new, at least,
maybe, or maybe a few laughs along the way,
Nathan Stephens: I should lower
the bar a lot because i'm not
i'm not great at it so so you're gonna have
to like look for the look for the humor,
Nathan Stephens: But I wanted i've done
data science for a while and i'm sure
we combined all the years here be you know
hundreds or thousands of years, probably
doing data analysis right and
in preparing for this analysis,
Nathan Stephens: In preparing for this
presentation, one of the first things I
did was open up excel and start putting ideas in
for my topic about why you should use R beyond,
Nathan Stephens: Just excel right so i'm
actually in excel doing work about things in R
so that that clued me in on like Okay, where
where are we here we're in this world where
excel is a big witness it's
everywhere it's built, you know,
Nathan Stephens: Oh, you know, I was going
to give I was going to pull in this whole
video about a from this account days right where,
Nathan Stephens: Guy says like they should visit
calculated they literally open up the wallet like
we will pay you anything for visit calc right
so like like that's back in the 70s, I think,
Nathan Stephens: Its own spreadsheets have
been here for a long time they're not going
away they're incredibly useful like I said
I used to prepare for this presentation,
Nathan Stephens: What I want to do is kind
of give an overview of this relationship
with programming languages so with that, let
me share my screen and we'll get started,
Nathan Stephens: excels not the problem it's
PowerPoint that's the problem you want to,
Nathan Stephens: Give,
Nathan Stephens: come out let's talk
PowerPoint then, then the knives come out yeah
so this will be, this will
be a friendly discussion,
Nathan Stephens: All right,
Scaling spreadsheets with R
Nathan Stephens: Why do we use Excel,
we use Excel for a lot of things right,
Nathan Stephens: But you know it in
R we have this notion of wrangling
visualizing transforming analyzing
and communicating insights about data,
Nathan Stephens: Which is exact same
thing that you're doing with with
excel right, so this is a very business
intelligence like mindset right like
and a lot of this presentation is about
like you're making decisions influencing,
Nathan Stephens: You know,
taking actions to see results right in a
in a business setting right, you can use,
Nathan Stephens: excel to build a wedding list,
too, and some people at our studio have used
R to build their wedding list, they
will go unnamed but I know who they are,
Nathan Stephens: In general we're gonna
be talking about businesses right so
there's a nice overlap here between
what you're actually doing them the bi
world between excel in our
in a lot of other languages,
a lot of other tools as well, like click sensor
tablo or you know or matlab or SAS right so,
Nathan Stephens: So anyway we're
on familiar territory, whatever,
Nathan Stephens: If you,
Nathan Stephens: If you've used excel
to any extent, you know that you end up
with some problems that your adult works
boss is saying, did you see any errors on
the spreadsheet and it's like only three,
Nathan Stephens: What are they your data your
format and your formulas right, so we know that,
as you use the spreadsheets you know you
kind of run into some problems and that's,
Nathan Stephens: Where I want to talk
about how R can address some of those
problems i'm going to actually
focus on two problems today,
Nathan Stephens: The first
one is file size okay so excel
handles kilobytes megabytes no problem right
when you start getting into like the gigabytes
right and 10s of gigabytes like lots of problems
right, it becomes much more difficult and,
Nathan Stephens: Do introducing large amounts of
data to excel is kind of like a fireball for me
and then this cartoon actually represents both
sides of my personality, as I get into large,
Nathan Stephens: files right or the coals
hot yes they're very hot i'm just about to
put on hamburgers before you do you toss into
Canada lighter fluid to make a giant fireball,
Nathan Stephens: And i've got the most boring data
in the world right So when I like trying to blow
up an excel spreadsheet it's like that you know
fireball but there's other actor in my head going
yeah you don't want to do this Calvin
like this is not a good idea right so,
Nathan Stephens: excel does
have some hard limits so,
Nathan Stephens: In a spreadsheet
spreadsheets limited by a million
rows and 16 1716 17,000 columns right hard limits,
Nathan Stephens: Good luck pushing on
that wall right there's some software
limits to around like the memory
limitations like I said earlier,
Nathan Stephens: megabytes sweet spot right
10s of megabytes no problem
serving the hundreds of megabytes,
Nathan Stephens: A little a little more
difficult right, and then you talk about like
10s of gigabytes that's an that's a no go
like that's that's no bueno is not very good,
Nathan Stephens: At least for the excel
spreadsheet Now I know now, I have to be careful,
because I know there's some real pros out there
that are more advanced excel than I am and,
Nathan Stephens: we're going to talk
about that right we're talking about
that that's what's coming up so
just hold it hold your fire okay,
Nathan Stephens: So the second problem, I want
to talk about is complexity right and complexity,
Nathan Stephens: Is a nebulous topic
right i'm taking a multi dimensional space
and put into one layton factor called
complexity right and i'm going to i'm
going to define complexity, for my
own purposes in this presentation,
Nathan Stephens: But I think there's some
intuitive field, here too, because, like I
pulled this right off, you know X KC D right the
most complicated thing and planets a sprawling
excel spreadsheet built up over 20 years by church
group in nebraska coordinating and scheduling,
Nathan Stephens: we've all seen it we've all seen
that spreadsheet right that's complicated but
let's put a little bit more meat on the bones and
say what, what are we talking about by complexity,
Nathan Stephens: Well, I think, if you have,
I think a simple workbook looks something like
this right it's like a single data source,
Nathan Stephens: Some summary statistics it's
no data updates it's got a few functions that
are easy to understand, maybe throw in
a drop down list, for you know fancy
you know use case show off a little bit,
you have a couple pivot tables and just a,
Nathan Stephens: handful of sheets, maybe just one
right or maybe you know six or seven not too many,
Nathan Stephens: A complex workbook but,
by contrast with be many data sources with
advanced algorithms built into it somehow
right and then dynamically updating the data
on a regular basis with your formulas to get,
Nathan Stephens: To and, like the thing drops down
fills up half the screen all the formulas
are nested like seven times over,
Nathan Stephens: there's visual basic
script writing the background you've got
several pivot tables or charts and
they're all sharing data so they're
all kind of like linked to the same spreadsheet,
Nathan Stephens: And you've got you know,
maybe dozens or hundreds of spreadsheets like
those things are terrified right
you open up the spreadsheet you
like there's no end of the number
of spreadsheets in this workbook,
Nathan Stephens: that's complicated right
so that's what I mean by complex right
there's a wide spectrum right, and
you can kind of fill in the blanks,
Nathan Stephens: So why scale spreadsheets with
R well R can handle far more data in excel so
itself the sweet spots really not megabyte
range in R the sweet spots in the gigabyte,
Nathan Stephens: Right so like handling a gigabyte
or 10 gigabytes no problem in R no problem at all,
Nathan Stephens: R can also handle much
more complexity than excel because it's
code base right, so a complex workbook and excel,
Nathan Stephens: equals a simple script and
art so i'm going to come back to this previous
slide there for a second, so this complex
workbook over here in this other column,
Nathan Stephens: That is what we call a simple
R script right so that's simple for R in fact
that's why you want to use R because ours really
good at these things right so i'm going to show
that in my demonstration that are actually
can do these things really quite easily,
Nathan Stephens: so simple
in R he was complex and excel
alright, so if you put these two
dimensions on two axes right,
Nathan Stephens: And you say i've got a
simple design and complex design and the
smallest and the on one and small
size, large size, on the other, axis,
Nathan Stephens: Then excel fits neatly, in
my opinion, my estimation around these small,
Nathan Stephens: file sizes with simple designs
no problem that's great that's why I was using
them to prepare for this presentation,
I was actually inputting the data right
itself so that's great pull it up put some
data in there and monkey around beautiful,
Nathan Stephens: When things get really
complicated are really large so we're thinking
like that previous thing like multiple levels
and data sources and update all this stuff right,
Nathan Stephens: I would argue,
ours really good at that right and
and can you use excel in that world,
Nathan Stephens: yeah yeah yeah you
guys seen some really creative uses, but
our is our is really good at that I don't
really want to talk about these quadrants
any more than I already had what I really
want to talk about is the off tags,
Nathan Stephens: I want to look at where when you
have something that's fairly fault small file size
but very complicated like when would you
think about using R instead of excel,
Nathan Stephens: And when you have something
that's really large files large file size but it's
very, very simple data structure, just like you
know one table that's just a little too big like,
Nathan Stephens: Where do you think
about using R in that dimension so
i'm very interested in this boundary
right and defining this boundary at
least that's what this talk is about it's
like what does this boundary look like,
Nathan Stephens: What When does it make sense to
start thinking about maybe leaving
the excel world and trying,
Nathan Stephens: Some functions in R so that's
what we're going to talk about today i've got
two problems i'm going to show you and the first
one in each quadrant The first one is going to be
where the files are too large, but
the design is very, very simple,
Nathan Stephens: So I have
to stop this presentation,
Nathan Stephens: To the Web OK, so the data,
where the first data we're going to use is,
Nathan Stephens: Popular baby names
from the social security administration
that are state specific, this is a zip file
like click on this and start downloading
things you have downloaded four
times right it's 21 megabytes right
downloads very quickly, and if you
open it up, it looks something like,
Nathan Stephens: That,
Nathan Stephens: like this names by State
this is the zip here in zip it it's got,
Nathan Stephens: Washington DC,
Nathan Stephens: And you open
up Arkansas, for example,
Nathan Stephens: and get this this
file right pretty straightforward
can open these up into excel which I did,
and this is what it looks like in itself,
Nathan Stephens: Okay, so here's Arkansas,
Nathan Stephens: And I loaded up every
single state into excel and I did some
googling about like how to do that
the best and I came to the conclusion
is probably the easiest if I just do this by hand,
Nathan Stephens: It took somewhere
between five and 10 minutes to load
everything in that every state
now all of these things are fine,
Nathan Stephens: For each State because they all
fit So if I come over here to come over here to,
Nathan Stephens: Arkansas you
can see that there was about
330 thousand names something like
that 30,000 names no problem right,
Nathan Stephens: But there's some there's
one issues here right off the BAT right so,
Nathan Stephens: The first issue already
mentioned it, I did like load them all up
that was kind of a pain, but one time cost
right so that's done but not many headers,
Nathan Stephens: So I need to go back, I went with
the headers and now I gotta put headers into 50
files and that's that's a pain, I did I didn't
bother to do that, because that sounds like a
nightmare waiting to happen right,
Nathan Stephens: When I put all the data together
yeah it was 21 megabyte zipped but, when it was
unzipped it was 120 megabytes and that's what it
is an excel file to it's around 120 megabytes,
Nathan Stephens: And that's large enough to
get the spinning wheel on the auto updates
that require you get the you know escape
on the Council because i'll be using it,
and then we'll just stop you know working,
Nathan Stephens: Then you've
got things like you know the,
Nathan Stephens: pivot tables here, are you know
one state, at a time that seems to be okay, except
I found something really interesting in
this process when I got to California,
Nathan Stephens: I was looking for names and
it turns out this drop down menu has a list
a cap of about 10,000 names and in California
is 20,000 names in this thing so so I can
just get up to carry and then I can't
get any I can't get beyond that right,
Nathan Stephens: So that's
that's frustrating, you know
and i'm just certainly had some
rough edges here, but the real,
Nathan Stephens: Hard edge is like
I don't really want to do the state
based I want to combine everything
and then analyze across states,
Nathan Stephens: And this thing is over
6 million records long it's not going
to fit into a worksheet right, so I
have to figure out some other way,
Nathan Stephens: to handle it now,
there are many ways to handle I mentioned
before you got bi tools right you've got,
Nathan Stephens: Other programming languages,
you can pull up Python right, if you want to,
but this is not a talk about
Python just to talk about art,
so I want to show you what
this would look like in part,
Nathan Stephens: So again, one of the big issues
here is I can't load all the data into our,
Nathan Stephens: me show you what it
looks like this to load in one state
that come into important data,
Nathan Stephens: So if you've never seen
Rstudio I don't know if anyone's nude Rstudio,
but this is this is Rstudio right you
get the R prompt down low your script
up hi got some tools over here on the right,
Nathan Stephens: So i'm going to
go ahead and read in the data i'm
going to browse for the data and
go here and pull up Arkansas again,
Nathan Stephens: and
Nathan Stephens: I keep saying Arkansas
aka aka Alaska Alaska isn't it,
so I should know better i've been
to Alaska there's an Arkansas,
Nathan Stephens: OK so we're gonna pull
up Alaska and notice the headers are off
right we're gonna have a header so
we're gonna get rid of the headers,
Nathan Stephens: Okay, good Now we just have
generic headers this is messed up to right
this is supposed to be male female and the F
and the female the computer things it's a false,
for some reason, so we're going
to change this to a character,
Nathan Stephens: There you go now your male female
and you can see that it actually wrote the code
for me over here right it just did all for me,
which is really nice so go ahead and import,
Nathan Stephens: know and and there's
my code, so I can get that code in there
really easily, and I can do
some fun things like I can do,
Nathan Stephens: let's do I can filter
this thing and say, I want to filter Ak,
which is the name of the data set
and i'll say like name equals Jesse,
Nathan Stephens: What did I do wrong Oh, because
there's no name there's no headers on this
one so it's got to be X four and so there's my
filter data set, and I can plot it if I want to,
Nathan Stephens: Do a GG plot,
and I can do some steps here,
you want to do here, which is X
three by count, which is X five,
Nathan Stephens: And I want to do a wind block,
Nathan Stephens: ago there's a line,
and now it looks different than,
Nathan Stephens: The one that we
did in excel because excel one,
Nathan Stephens: actually had
categorical names on that search right,
so we have to fix that right these
these years or not, so it goes from,
Nathan Stephens: In the same increments that it
went from 1992 1993 So this is the more accurate,
Nathan Stephens: Data right Okay, so this is
great, so I can come in here and kind of tool
around a little bit news fuel are things to like
you know going to feel today, but that was my,
Nathan Stephens: My my heart edge my order was
reading all the data, and so let
me Let me read in all the data,
Nathan Stephens: And the way I do that i'm
going to use the broom package because the
broom package makes us really easy
it's a very good package for like,
Nathan Stephens: Loading and lots
of data, so if you're like many
gigabytes that's great we just have
128 it's going to be lightning fast,
Nathan Stephens: And then go ahead
and grab grab all the files in that
directory So these are all the files and the
room command says just take the files and,
Nathan Stephens: Take the column and add a
column header right, so I don't have to like
do that 50 times that's really simple command
let's go ahead and see what bring business,
Nathan Stephens: So it says
that we have 6000 records
right five columns and this tells
me all those columns and I can,
Nathan Stephens: You can take a look
at that if I want to or I cannot save
it so i'm actually gonna write this back
to file i'm going to write this as a csv,
Nathan Stephens: won't take too long because
it's cranking away great piece of cake right
super fast super easy no problem I now have
one file that's concatenate all of them,
Nathan Stephens: No mistakes in the code,
because I wasn't gonna be copying and
pasting right so simple concatenation,
Nathan Stephens: say, well, I can do concatenation
of files and any number of ways right like yes,
yes, you can but here's the thing
like we're just going to make,
Nathan Stephens: we're going to jump right
into some exploratory data analysis now,
one thing that excel has that are doesn't have is
this notion of notebooks right so notebooks are,
Nathan Stephens: formats that contain the
pros and the Code and the results of the code,
all in the same document and they're really
useful because it lets you keep track of your
thought process right So if you go back later,
you can see why what you were thinking doing,
Nathan Stephens: Which is why it's
called a notebook right so Leonardo
da Vinci was famous for his notebooks you know
back in the day they're still popular debate,
and so this way and our notebook looks like,
Nathan Stephens: This is,
Nathan Stephens: The dismiss speaker notes,
yes that's right, I was going to show you my
speaker notes, because this is where we come into,
Nathan Stephens: yeah so here's my data
analysis I showed you, and then the files,
so I wrote a notebook to keep track of my
speaker notes right you're seeing that the
process that I went through to do this,
Nathan Stephens: there's the room right
that we just did, and then we get to we
get to this one here, so I put in a spaceballs
if you ever seen spaceballs they get the now,
Nathan Stephens: A situation where
they're looking at the movie in real time,
and he says you're looking at now everything
that happens now is happening now right and rick
Miranda says this is now what happened
to Ben he says we pass them when now,
Nathan Stephens: When will then be now
soon right so that's coming soon alright,
so let me show you the notebook I really
wanted to show you so here's the setup,
Nathan Stephens: I can load my packages in here
now for the you know the people that have been
using R for a while, you might have already have
some preferences for how you load in your data,
Nathan Stephens: I showed you to
hear already to read csv is that,
as part of the you know read our package, the room
is package is really cool it's part of the Tigers,
Nathan Stephens: there's this other really
popular one called F3 right and if reads,
Nathan Stephens: lightning fast super good
so you just pick which one you want right
and there's more than that, but these are
three of the most popular ones, you know
if you have lots of data that these become
really important distinctions right Okay, so
now i'm going to do my data analysis now,
Nathan Stephens: I just want to
backtrack for one second back to this,
Nathan Stephens: graphic here it come back
here when you go into this larger file
size area where you know data becomes largish
almost universally you're going to default
back to something that's like sequel,
Nathan Stephens: No matter what tool
you're using it's going to be look very
sequel like right and that's no different
with R so in R i'm going to use a tool
called dplyr and the player looks like
sql because it uses the notion of verbs,
Nathan Stephens: And this is what that looks like
right so i've got a filter statement, instead
of aware right, I have a group by statement a
summarized statement which is like you know the
aggregate you know variables in the
select statement or the window variables,
Nathan Stephens: And then I do actually having a
select statement here at the end right, so this is
how you would manipulate data very sequel like way
of doing the data so go ahead and run that code,
Nathan Stephens: don't think
there's much output there
and that will just kind of monkey
around a little bit we'll look at
most popular names from 1996 and what
happened to this particular niche right,
Nathan Stephens: Oh now what's going on, oh,
Nathan Stephens: Well, that would not,
Nathan Stephens: be a surprise without,
Nathan Stephens: A live
DEMO without some error okay
that must be that must be a bug
in the visual editor so i've been,
Nathan Stephens: This is what
the documents typically look like
and arm in Rmarkdown and our
notebooks the default view
what I was showing you earlier, was what
is a new feature called the visual editor,
Nathan Stephens: So you can kind of
toggle between these two visual editor
is this format, it is going to give you
a more like Jupiter notebook feel to it
and, for some reason it's not showing me my,
Nathan Stephens: output, so the way
you start you solve this as you refresh
your session and start over but i'm just
going to go ahead and stick with the old,
Nathan Stephens: The old notebook I think
here just stick with the old version
there you go most popular names 99 six and
which is Emily JESSICA Matthew and Michael and,
Nathan Stephens: And then, if you look
at the most popular names leading up
in 2020 last year, the most popular and
answered a the mo Liam know all over and olivia
and olivia just going strong
just going strong okay so,
Nathan Stephens: yeah and this shows you that
the run up so olivia is this purple line right,
and you can see it's been going
strong for quite a while and rename,
Nathan Stephens: All right, and then
you can look at these shared names right
so i'm going to take a look at these names that
maybe are shared by both the Multi gendered names,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So quick question is it
would you be able to enlarge
the font size, a little bit,
Nathan Stephens: Oh, is it
is it kind of small let's,
Nathan Stephens: Was that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Nathan Stephens: yeah and then,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well i'm
asking you questions one other question,
because I know it's not a lot of people's mind
is, will you share this script with us after,
Nathan Stephens: yeah yeah yeah it's
on github already it's in the notes and
yeah it's all there for you cool,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Nathan Stephens: Okay, so basically you get to
this and you're like Okay, this is cool like
you know I might have something to say about this
right, I want to do something so i'm going to,
Nathan Stephens: run build an application on this,
the shiny application is not a shiny DEMO
so i'm just gonna leave it at that this is
how you can build applications and are going to
run that APP and show you what that looks like,
Nathan Stephens: So in the shiny APP when I blown
it up so much I can't really see it, so let me,
let me open up a window here there we go,
Nathan Stephens:
Okay, so this is Jesse and I can go ahead and
add in like Colorado and California right,
Nathan Stephens: And that's the name of
Jesse and you can see that jesse's share
mostly a male name right and there's
some females named Jesse as well,
so this is what the female view you know looks
like here and the cool thing here is like
all of the names are in here,
I can pick any name I wanted,
Nathan Stephens: Jesse because, for some reason
I was thinking about uncle Jesse and I pulled
the name and I was like okay i'm Jesse was
popular right about here so good good job
john stamos he pretty much killed the name, so if
you want to pick a different name, though, like,
Nathan Stephens: Rebecca which I think was his
love interest you can see that you know you
can beginning anyone, which is really cool,
this is a very simple APP now, if you want to
share this application online you do this with,
Nathan Stephens: You know RStudios
product which is RStudio connect
and so you can publish this thing with a push
of a button and then share it with other people
and that becomes very powerful tool to
use the enterprise right, you can also,
Nathan Stephens: share the notebook
right so here's the notebook
that's also on connect, and this will
allow you to keep track of your content not
other people to collaborate to
or to see what you're doing,
Nathan Stephens: So that, in a nutshell,
is sighs i'm going to keep moving here
because i'm going to run out of time,
Nathan Stephens: The next thing I want to
talk about was this quadrant here around,
Nathan Stephens: Where the workbook is too complex
so we're going to toggle over and talk about
something file that's pretty small but the
workbook ends up being really complicated, so let
me do that here connected with sell new data set
Okay, this new data set this is about customer,
Nathan Stephens: Data This is called a
growth equation that breaks down revenue
and constituent parts and it's got these little
drop Downs right, where I can choose a segment
I can choose a metric and I can either
be your you know year to date or whatnot,
Nathan Stephens: And I worked really hard on
this thing this thing took a long time to build
I mean we're talking weeks to build this thing
right, and this is actually the simplified view,
Nathan Stephens: In in all of its glory is
actually a lot more sophisticated than this,
but basically you're pulling
some some data, the pre period
you pull some data in the
post period you're right some,
Nathan Stephens: You know, look ups
here some offsets to like get the
data that you need based on the
inputs hearing the parameters,
Nathan Stephens: table and then pretty it up here
and you do, that every week and you mail it out,
and you know people that liked it go oh cool
copy and paste it and they use it to right now,
Nathan Stephens: There was a problem with this
thing that I ran into that and that was that
it was really hard to maintain,
Nathan Stephens: Like it was always changing
and any change was very difficult to make
and sometimes the data we're really hard to get
right because the data coming in such a way that,
Nathan Stephens: Even the smallest
changes were hard to track down,
so this thing that was you know come
my pride and joy and being kind of this
taskmaster monster, for me, you know, trying
to create this beast and it's, so much so that,
Nathan Stephens: Anyway, i'll just leave it
at that the best of attention, sometimes don't
plan out play out well and unfortunately
the the, the bottom line here is that,
Nathan Stephens: You know this took a lot
of time and ultimately yield the you know
the one of the best results here was I became
very good at excel so so there was that but,
like from a business guy you perspective, I
think the business is a little bit off so,
Nathan Stephens: Let me show
you what this looks like in art,
Nathan Stephens: Alright, so in our,
Nathan Stephens:
This is another application
little hard to see here but,
Nathan Stephens: This is, this
is the application it's not it's
it's really not that bad it's it's not that bad of
a shiny application, let me go ahead and run it,
Nathan Stephens: So we're here there we go cool
so I can choose my segment right, I can
choose I can do all the same stuff right,
Nathan Stephens: And i've got my output
here, which is really nice and I can download
the data set right, and this is really
cool because, if I open up this thing,
Nathan Stephens: actually get back to the
cell output right with the chart and the data,
Nathan Stephens: And I actually get the data that
it used to create those metrics here so that's
really that that's really nice,
because then you're just pulling
the exact data that you want, and
the users can do it themselves now,
Nathan Stephens: Again, this is something
that you're probably going to want to
publish to connect, and this is what
it looks like and connect, this is a,
Nathan Stephens: You know tool where everybody can
access it and honestly, you know at this point,
this is really a fancy and nice but i've
kind of gone above and beyond it, you know,
Nathan Stephens: shiny Apps are sexy and
interesting because you know interact with the
reactive right and people like that and straight,
but it doesn't have to be that way, and there
are some negatives to this as well because,
Nathan Stephens: Getting this
report means I have to like you know
get in here to the application, then
get what I want and download it,
Nathan Stephens: it's like sometimes you just want
to email out your results right it's like this is
the report email it out, you know executives they
don't want to look at an APP anyway, they just
live in their email so, so in that situation
you use a report and the report here,
Nathan Stephens: looks like this, this is the
arm markdown, and this is actually a simpler
thing to do, because you put all of your
parameters here at the top and the header,
Nathan Stephens: And then all of your stuff
this year now now one of the cool things I
really like about the script is is stuff like
this, this shows me all my formulas right like
anybody can read this anyone on this call
can read this was like, how do you define,
Nathan Stephens: let's see
like what is it like items,
Nathan Stephens: Like spend pre right well it's
the dollars pre divided by the items pre The pre
those that's that's how that's calculated
that's a really nice way to look at your code
right So if you want to nip this thing
in come up here to knit with parameters,
Nathan Stephens: You can just
choose you know the things here
like the shiny APP, this is
actually a shiny gadgets,
Nathan Stephens: That this thing, and it
will give you the report that you want,
and this is actually a little easier
to maintain and if you put this into
if you put the same report into connect you can,
Nathan Stephens:
Do this really cool thing we can like email
yourself, so this is that same report and connect,
Nathan Stephens: i'm going to send that email, you
can come up here, you can choose the parameters
that you want so it's all cool right so, but you
don't even need connect to do is actually like you
can easily like just generate these reports from
the code and, and this is what they look like on,
Nathan Stephens: The mail system right
they come across looking like this,
where you get this Nice, you know body
and you get the down the attachments here,
Nathan Stephens: Okay, so this report
this code, here we come back to the code,
Nathan Stephens: This code here
I dusted off that thing that took
like weeks and weeks to build and I recreated
it from the ground up in our in about six hours,
Nathan Stephens: from six weeks to six
hours literally Okay, so when we talk
about complexity that's what i'm talking about
like writing the code here like art that that,
Nathan Stephens: Things complex workbooks
just becomes simple and are and they become
more, and I would argue, to become more
accurate to at least in my experience,
but they become a lot simpler to do
in life okay So, in summary here,
Nathan Stephens: How do you
scale spreadsheets and far,
Nathan Stephens: boy that takes a long time, again
I got to do a presentation on PowerPoint Okay,
how do you scale spreadsheets or by using powerful
coding tools that make you work reproducible
and communicate with Apps and notebooks so if,
Nathan Stephens: You know
you're ever in a situation,
Nathan Stephens: If you've ever been in situation
where you feel like your hands are being burned,
Nathan Stephens: Discussion in your excel
you know notebooks or you're like sweating
to get through the excel notebooks I would
suggest that a maybe there's a better way
right maybe there's another tool and here,
Nathan Stephens: zog has a stick right so
dogs actually figured out a better way to
deal with the fire right,
Nathan Stephens: So this boundary hopefully
is boundaries, a little bit clear, I think,
Nathan Stephens: I know I drew it is
a hard line I actually think that's
a pretty wide spectrum right I think
there's a pretty big difference between,
Nathan Stephens: You know what spot
you're going to move from excel to our
but hopefully this presentation has helped clarify
like why you would use our instead of excel,
Nathan Stephens: Even in the event you're not
doing like a bunch of random forests right,
even in the event, where you just need to do some
you know regular old data science exploration,
Nathan Stephens: So, the last thing I will say
is that, in this our space, you know you're doing
data science, you know you can do data science and
excel right, you can do an art and the excel is,
Nathan Stephens: A great tool it's got
his turn complete right it's got power
query built into it right, you can publish
things to power bi you know you can,
Nathan Stephens: got the visual basic and the
back end which is not really my cup of tea, but,
Nathan Stephens: It is a programming
language and it works, and it can be
tracking conversion control itself,
you can do all those things in excel,
Nathan Stephens: The Nice, one of the nice
things about our, is it really clarifies
when you're using the code and,
Nathan Stephens: i'm going to suggest
to you that you know data science,
the source for all your results
really is your code it's not,
Nathan Stephens: it's not the
report it's not the output,
but it's the process that you use to get the code
so in excel if you think about excel and you like
share some output from excel or like empowered,
Nathan Stephens: So you take some pivot
tables from an example of them into PowerPoint
so that's Nice that output is really
valuable, but the source for that
was the process that you went through
to get that information, it was,
Nathan Stephens: queried my your micro strategy
with a specific query and then loading it up and
then doing some manipulations doing some cleaning
like doing some explorations building some charts,
Nathan Stephens: that whole process is where
the value is in data science and we use things
like are strictly or you know code or scripting
language like you get that part as a natural part
of the process okay so that's some references here
and i'm going to pause and see what questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm happy to help
read the questions and just wanted to let people
know again that we do have the
slideshow link for questions, too,
so you can either ask with your name
and or ask it live or ask anonymously,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But Christina
I see you just ask the question around
what if the executive wants the report
for every combination of parameters,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Do you have strategies
to iterate through them and generate a full PDF
report and Christina feel free to jump in
and add any other context to if you want to,
Nathan Stephens: yeah so if your
Executive once every combination,
it sounds like your Executive
wants to data science,
Nathan Stephens: Oh, you can build
tools for that date that executive to do
the data science and that's what you
would do with the shiny application,
and so you build a shiny
application and put that out there,
Nathan Stephens: yeah it sounds like
you're very interesting executive
my experiences executives usually
they want the bottom line,
and so you might be an opportunity to hear that
you know, help the do some his own analysis,
Christina Ross: Well, this is it's
christina's my wife, but this is Casey
the tool we actually do our tablo
dashboards but then we also have to publish,
Christina Ross: All like we have to do all
the filters for like every combination,
basically, and then we have this like c++
program that takes web shots of all of them, and
like put this report together and it's a really,
Christina Ross: complicated process that's
what that's what I was getting at with that,
Nathan Stephens: that's so interesting I actually
I actually took that part
of this presentation out,
Nathan Stephens: But I gave this fruit so it's
I can send you a link to another version this
presentation actually does the Web shots
puts them into PowerPoint presentations
programmatically and of would allow you to
do something like that, I think that the,
Nathan Stephens: So tablo is a great tool right
tableaus tableau and our our studio products are
basically solving the same problem it's
just the artist with code and tablo is not,
Nathan Stephens: So I i'd be
surprised if there were things
that you're doing interval that you
can do, above and beyond, with art,
Nathan Stephens: But the thing that you
mentioned, where you're talking about like
programmatically pulling all combinations
and web shots put in visitation
yes that's all possible and i've done it,
Christina Ross: The,
Nathan Stephens: Link yeah,
Christina Ross: Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
Thank you and and one question, I saw that quickly
got to upload son flatow Leo asked, could you
please show a quick, step by step, to achieve that
awesome email with the graph and format a table,
Nathan Stephens: Or you want to
see how the email is created,
Nathan Stephens: yeah yeah I can do that, and as
you go back and i'll do the PowerPoint into the,
screen,
Nathan Stephens: I appreciate
that interest in the code I,
Nathan Stephens: See when I do,
speaker notes,
Nathan Stephens: Okay, so in the arm markdown
version it's going to look like this,
Nathan Stephens: i'm going to say compose
the email right here and what's the name
of this package which you remember blast
eula is the package that we're looking for,
Nathan Stephens: And then dt is another
one that you're looking for, like the,
Nathan Stephens: No, no GT GT GT GT grammar tables
and black sheila, but this is where I put in the,
Nathan Stephens: Subject line right,
and this is where to find the,
Nathan Stephens: plot, and then I compose the
email this looks this might look like comments,
but this is all being recognized by our
right, so this is like actually pulling in,
Nathan Stephens: The things in are inserting
them into the content of the document,
and you can read all about that in the blaster
help site and then on the arm markdown,
Nathan Stephens: side, you have to attach
the subject line here, so this is
the subject line, this is the body,
these are images and these are attaching so the
sls file gets attached here in the markdown file,
Nathan Stephens: make sense, so what
that's going to this is all that the
email I also make that excel file here
available as a link to the report and
that's this in our studio connect to feature but,
Nathan Stephens: Because I can
make it work really nicely, but
this is the this is, I think
what you're looking for,
Nathan Stephens: I wanted to just briefly
mentioned, I didn't take out the the PowerPoint
thing I just want to make sure that that you're
aware that when we do like a presentation here,
Nathan Stephens: are marked down
to come here to presentation on are more
than one of the options is PowerPoint,
Nathan Stephens: So you can actually
generate power points here, and then in
PowerPoint going back to the web shots
you can put web shots in here to like
pick up the things that we're trying to insert,
Nathan Stephens: What else,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I see a
conversation in the zoom chat right now
and Cassandra asked what level of security is
available and using our studio in a shiny up
because they work in the Treasury
with sensitive banking information,
and I see someone else also works in banking to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah,
Nathan Stephens: So we take, we take
security very seriously at our studio,
Nathan Stephens: it's always
the mind so i've been able to,
Nathan Stephens: Be around for a while and
I used to process all the security reviews
when I first started it was a tiny
company, so I had to go through all that,
but it became very clear to me early
on that we don't have a company
without secure software so i'm not
saying that we've got everything,
Nathan Stephens: figured out because it's an
ongoing process, but I will tell you that you know
we have onboarding hundreds of customer that i've
had a variety of security needs and we haven't
lost any deals specifically because security
so they come into support here and do security,
Nathan Stephens: there's packet security,
Nathan Stephens: security package downloads I
think this is probably a good place so ssl right,
Nathan Stephens: Cross origin
resource sharing right,
Nathan Stephens: Yes, there's,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): specific
questions to i'm always happy to
take that offline and help
connect you with the right person
internally i'll just put my email
there too, if that's useful yeah,
Nathan Stephens: Well, I think
the general question is, you know,
can I trust you know my shiny applications
and keep in mind that normally the shiny
applications are used for internal purposes,
Nathan Stephens: Like normally you're like
you're putting this behind your firewall
so that's usually the standard you're
looking for is like is it secure all,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): make sense, I
see another anonymous question that was
excel may be considered as
interactive APP for data analysis,
how do you help excel user successfully
transition to a shiny APP developer,
Nathan Stephens: Well yeah you're in
luck, I mean there are a lot of resources
around learning new shiny So if you go to,
Nathan Stephens: wasn't sure shiny dark studio
COM that's a great place to get started,
Nathan Stephens: The creator of shiny
his job chain and in Chinese 10 years
old now it's been around for a while,
but the cool thing about shiny is that,
Nathan Stephens: was designed to fail nicely so
don't talks about the pit of success right, so
you might make him this mistake but
shine is going to be nice to you,
you know when you make that mistake it'll give
you a little like find something else to do,
Nathan Stephens: or it'll give you a
warning or you know a little like help
you try to figure out the best way to do it,
so the way if you're transitioning to shiny,
Nathan Stephens: be nice to
yourself start simple and then
just follow the patterns and fall into that pit
of success, I say that myself because i'm not the,
Nathan Stephens: world's best shiny APP developer,
I have my backgrounds and big data right,
and so, not as opposed to front
end, you know application design,
Nathan Stephens: But I have learned the
just dealing with going with the patterns going
with the flow you're going to have a pretty
gentle right, but the shiny and if you do have
problems I go to Community to our studio COM,
Nathan Stephens: there's a lot of
resources on the Community site about
getting shiny and you can ask questions like
you would like, in a stack overflow situation,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I think it
can also be helpful to check out the
shiny gallery to and i'll put that in the chat,
Nathan Stephens: Definitely,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But it
can give you a good starting point,
if you see something that you hear this kind
of like what you want to do and go from there,
Nathan Stephens: That
I will point out one thing that's interesting
about shiny is that reactive nature,
Nathan Stephens: is very similar to the
excel paradigm right so in excel you change
one cell and it just trickles through the whole
spreadsheet and can just have massive changes to
the experience Chinese the same way you'll change
one thing, and it will just reactive Lee like,
Nathan Stephens: percolate through the entire
application it's pretty cool it's cool stuff,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Another
question on slide oh from josh was
tools such as get have sequel power bi tablo
excel curious your thoughts on these tools that
as they don't seem to be emphasized enough
with respect to their use in the workplace,
Nathan Stephens: tools i'm struggling with
that question a little bit, because in my
in my your ideal customers on a daily basis, and
it seems like everybody's using those tools so,
Nathan Stephens: We get so many questions
about that and sequel has been or it's just
been such a dominant paradigm for so long,
I was joking with my friends like I I did a,
Nathan Stephens: You know i've worked with no
no sequel databases for quite a while right like
not know structured things like
like tablo or you know read us and,
Nathan Stephens: They always there's always some
sort of sequel mess around it you're like hi
right it's not even sequel but they put html
on top of it so, so I think sequel is one of
the most enduring paradigms and technology
that i'm aware of and don't bet against it,
Nathan Stephens: I think it's great
I think I think everyone should
I sequels just a skill that's
great to have I do think I don't want to riff
too long on this because I could go on, but the,
Nathan Stephens: I think one of the problems with
sequel in general with with the world is like,
very few people get formalized sequel training,
I was lucky enough to get that
right, so I learned sequel,
Nathan Stephens: On the job like that nobody in
academia talks about sequel right and he go to
say, nobody, but nobody in my
experience in academia ever
mentioned anything about sequel
and then I go into the job,
Nathan Stephens: And that's all anybody who's
doing so I learned sequel that way, but then
actually did take a training class and sequel and
they talked about the cruise planners right and,
Nathan Stephens: You know other clauses that
you know, maybe not so familiar with and,
Nathan Stephens: And and window
functions and different sides of
that was very useful So if you if you
really wanted to do something hardcore
you can get formalized training
I don't think it's necessary,
Nathan Stephens: But if it makes you feel like
more of an expert feel better about your skills,
like those things are out them,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): cash, let us know if
we missed anything in that question to jumping,
Nathan Stephens: all around,
Josh Rodriguez: If I could kind of
just clarify, I think you did end
up touching on what I bet there's a limit
on the words or letters, you can use but,
Josh Rodriguez: So with our I learned a lot
about our through school barely was exposed to
any of the other tools, so it seems now that
i'm backtracking to learn the other tools to
match my use with our that are
barely us are in the workplace,
Nathan Stephens: Oh okay yeah that makes sense
that makes a lot of sense,
so are you miss yeah are you,
Nathan Stephens: Missing are wanting to
integrate with those other solutions,
Josh Rodriguez: yeah I guess i'm just wondering
your thoughts on the emphasis around the other
tools, because they do say my sequel and
excel seems like something you'll want to
especially excel master that before you
master are based on its use in the workplace,
Nathan Stephens: I think our is
a niche programming language,
mostly used by scientists,
which seeking the truth and,
Nathan Stephens: If you still go to the our
project page today it'll say it's a language
for statistical computing and visualization
and the you know how many companies are
sitting around thinking I just I need,
Nathan Stephens: I need some statistical
computing visualization software around here,
Nathan Stephens: that's not what they're
thinking they got data they got operations
they've got bi they've got these big systems
they've got these enterprise requirements right
so it's not a surprise that like an academia,
Nathan Stephens: you're using our to do, science
and learning and then the industry is using
more enterprise tools that doesn't surprise me at
all, I think one of the yeah I can keep going on,
I think one of the reasons why I wanted to join
our studio was to help bridge that gap, but,
Nathan Stephens: I think yeah I can hear you
joshua and I should grab a cup of coffee and talk,
Nathan Stephens: I hear you,
Josh Rodriguez: sounds great,
lparkinson: i'd love to jump in on
that party, if I can some similar boat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
i'll schedule coffee anyway,
Maria Prokofieva: Yes, that's
exactly what i'm struggling with,
Nathan Stephens: What are
you struggling with Maria,
Maria Prokofieva: yeah well
that's exactly the gap,
Nathan Stephens: They give the gift that
too, as well yeah yeah like we're talking
about the gap between like we're talking
about evangelizing are showing like,
why are is relevant and
enterprise, are we getting it,
yeah yeah,
Nathan Stephens: Well Rachel that's
been a good fight for a long time,
do you wanna you want to respond to that you're
doing a lot of that work right now I really,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah definitely that's
that's exactly what I want to help teams with so
i'm going to say in the chat right now messaged
me if you want to get in on that virtual coffee,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But we should
we should set that up and chat more about I
don't want to kind of overtake this talk with
that, but maybe it should be another topic,
Nathan Stephens: I wrote a post, many years
ago, when I first joined our story about
making are legitimate in your organization and,
Nathan Stephens: The tenants of that
was to allocate was to make a decision
and allocate resources so you're
looking for a stakeholder,
Nathan Stephens: Usually someone very
senior in your organization to say
we will consider our to be an analytic standard,
Nathan Stephens: And we're going to support it,
just like we would sequel or these other tools
that you're talking about and then, if you can get
out resources allocate them, whether it be like
you know, like a server like
money or resources or software,
Nathan Stephens: Or you get individuals like
same we're going to change these individuals on
those things that's what you're looking
for right and that's the natural process
and most organizations to recognize standards and,
Nathan Stephens: they're just
because ours fairly small
it just hasn't gone through that process
there's an assumption that are is,
Nathan Stephens: That data sciences things that
people do on their laptops with free software
right, and I think that greatly
undermines the value of data science,
Nathan Stephens: I think that and it's
you know joshua point out Oh, what about tablo
right and what about power bi therapy has a
little over to the Microsoft right
so Microsoft different thing but,
Nathan Stephens: You know, all these other
tools well if you brought tablo in the
organization somebody went in there
and said we're going to make tablo,
Nathan Stephens: analytics standard for this
organization to allocate resources work you
have to do the same thing with your programming
language to say like this is just to be the JET
but that's that's all not post, I know that
Rachel yeah well i'm gonna stop talking now,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): knows i'm
happy to keep that conversation going but
Nathan, I was actually actually
didn't even tell you this yet,
but I was going through that post trying
to think about how we could revamp that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And so I may as well
just share it with you all here and figure, if you
have comments on things that Nathan, and I could
include there are things that would be useful,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But it's based off of
nathan's original article on making are
a legitimate part of your your company,
Nathan Stephens: Yes, i'll actually,
Nathan Stephens: i'll go ahead to stocking Maria,
Maria Prokofieva: Oh yeah that that was
nice any you know go Rachel because that's
That is exactly what i'm seeing like yeah we
all have that picture or working there
are person like you know in glasses,
Maria Prokofieva: Like you're just just
doing some really awesome things which
nobody really needs but we don't
really realize there's like
just one hands away like it loads of
things are much so much easier there,
Nathan Stephens: I think most organizations, want
to do things I think you said, like nobody needs
I my my experiences that most organizations aren't
very data driven right and there's a spectrum and,
Nathan Stephens: But, but they want to be,
and they know that it's relevant and I think
going through the process of saying
like you know, are you take all the,
Nathan Stephens: Emotions out of it and
say like you have a business to run right
we're talking just enterprise,
we have business to run,
Nathan Stephens: Our is a competitive
advantage that brings in great people,
it was these technologies that needs support
you're already using C sharp and you're using,
Nathan Stephens: Some Python and using Java, why
not use our and those are those are arguments
that you can when i've done it, I mean that's
been my history i've done this multiple times,
Nathan Stephens: As organizations, you can you can
win those arguments, because it makes sense right
it's like you take the emotion that people out
of it and say like hey we need this thing right,
Nathan Stephens: And you know
organization will struggle,
a little bit because they don't a lot of them
don't get data science we don't understand what
you guys are doing right but that's changing
that's all changing right like that's,
Nathan Stephens: Ai algorithm
or like common vernacular now in
the world like you know my grandma's passed on,
but if I had a grandma still so you would know
a day I wasn't even that should be pretty
ticked off that algorithms for some reason,
Maria Prokofieva: Both of them are not data driven
and for them it's one extra step of the to do,
and you know, like people are lazy
they don't really want an extra step,
Maria Prokofieva: If we can like,
Maria Prokofieva: If they don't have to
so before they realize all the
benefits they need to do effort,
Nathan Stephens: yeah yeah there's usually
some sort of fulcrum and getting that,
Nathan Stephens: executive sponsor is
key, like if there's no executive sponsor
no one's willing to actually say
yes that's what we're going to do,
then you really they're
back in that you're back in,
Nathan Stephens: The guerrilla warfare right
you're just back in there, like doing stuff and
you know, throwing spaghetti against
the wall and hoping it sticks right,
Nathan Stephens: And I had to say,
like if you're in that organization,
there are better organizations in that right like,
Nathan Stephens: Like if you're
looking to like make an impact,
make a difference and improve your skills
like Why would you want to be an organization that
didn't value data science right because that's,
Nathan Stephens: I don't know again, things
have changed like when I was starting my career,
I just had to find a job somewhere that
in and and data science and modeling were
only known to a very small group of your
your second looking for those people I,
Nathan Stephens: I have looked at job listings
all over the place and there's like a,
Nathan Stephens: ton of opportunities now so
it's still changing but I don't yeah I don't
I don't get organizations that just don't want
to give their data scientists any resources like
like maybe you don't want to be part of that
organization and that's just that's my feeling,
lparkinson: A bit organizations is our hiring,
Nathan Stephens: what's that,
lparkinson: I said, if there's
better organizations is our hiring,
Nathan Stephens: You mean our studio yes,
Nathan Stephens: or studios hired 800
people like almost a new person is
coming in almost every day right now
yeah so check the job listings yeah,
Maria Prokofieva: All fire
engine ships to international,
Maria Prokofieva: of fancy and
what's been waiting for that
and, like you just sort of downgrading like
your, we have to pay you this is not have to be,
Nathan Stephens: What I will say
that we don't do a lot of data
science at our studio right because we're
not a data, not a data organization,
where we build software right so that's
our our output of software not not,
Nathan Stephens: To think about the things I
showed you today, like the tracker you know,
like the customer data like
we don't have that data,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and Nathan, I know
we're a little bit over but there's still
quite a few questions I
was wondering if it's okay,
Nathan Stephens: or no, no i'm happy
to hang on here, this is really,
Nathan Stephens: yeah really rewarding and
ways that I can possibly explain right now,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, thank you
so much Nathan, and then also on that topic of
like hiring and companies that use our as well
on Community that our studio COM, there is also
like a jobs and gigs section, where a lot of our
customers and open source or pro post their jobs,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): but also for people
who are in this position of trying to convince
internally, you are definitely not alone, so
I don't think the only answer is it's going
somewhere else so would love to to chat
more about how we can help with that too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
But one of the questions,
From earlier Nathan, was what packages, do
you recommend for importing excel files,
Nathan Stephens: Well, the yeah
the easy one, was you know,
Nathan Stephens: for
importing excel files oh geez,
Nathan Stephens: should have done my
homework to see what's out there now
the there wasn't there were like a read sls and
then there's like an xlr sex package as well,
Nathan Stephens: yeah you know that's
a that's a miss my presentation,
because I was showing how to
read in the flat files, but
yeah just reading those things are pretty
straightforward, let me um let's see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
Everyone in the chat is,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): confirming
that it was it is reading so,
Nathan Stephens: So it's okay so,
Nathan Stephens: If I come in here to
environment important data set from excel
yeah read excel is the is the
one that's used by default,
there are there are others, I thought there
was an excel os X package some point but,
Nathan Stephens: it's the one that's the
one that our studio obviously recommends,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
And then another question from
earlier was can you version control excel I think,
Nathan Stephens: Maybe we met yeah there's
the one i'm familiar with is a paid
solution, though, so you actually have to
like subscribe to it it's an enterprise solution
which makes sense right because it sells,
Nathan Stephens: As an enterprise
tool like you have to pay for it, so
I kind of agree with that that's
one of the nice things about our
is that it's it is free right so
come on music starting easily,
Nathan Stephens: But yeah there's ways
yeah there are there are tools to do that
I can't recommend them
because I haven't used them,
Nathan Stephens: But last
few months ago they released
some new function that made a turing
complete you know so it's like it's like
excels there for for forever and it's not just
excel either right it's also Google sheets and,
Nathan Stephens: it's also openoffice
right so it's like you actually have
three you know spreadsheet
platforms to choose from,
Miguel Eersel: I need them with
me go if if this can quickly,
Miguel Eersel: share my my experiences i've
been using our and our model for three years,
using it in the enterprise business
I first started people introducing
getting them to know our
with that was a little step,
Miguel Eersel: To be but once I introduced
him to our markdown he could see the liquid XL
very easy very straightforward and they love our
markdown and then connects with them with excel,
Miguel Eersel: Because you can work in the
objects and generate nice reports easily
good step by step,
Miguel Eersel: And that is my experience
and how I use it no in the enterprise I
use it in the oil and gas, I would
use it in the marketing business,
Miguel Eersel: Is they have this era P system
Sep Microsoft dynamics and when they have to do
reporting we do system at this very commercial
and when they use our Margot on the way they
extract the data from the back end put it
in a small database access the data with,
Miguel Eersel: Our margo than it is for
them, etc, etc, really, they can generate
fantastic reports and they love it,
Miguel Eersel: it's my experience,
Nathan Stephens: yeah I appreciate that feedback
i'd be really so I showed the visual editor today
on the DEMO broken one point which was unfortunate
it's new i'd be curious to know your feedback
introducing the same people with visual editor
that actually made things even better for them,
Miguel Eersel: Yes, yes, you like it yeah,
Miguel Eersel: But they don't
like our body like our mark don't,
Miguel Eersel: You love online,
Nathan Stephens: Well, you know markdown me you
got our code chunks inside of our markdown so
like you can't really use our markdown
without our right like there's got,
Nathan Stephens: Yes, but you're saying they
don't like the art script they'd rather,
Miguel Eersel: Just in,
Miguel Eersel: Our script
be like, on my own and fine,
Miguel Eersel: yeah because it's easier to
understand connect with excel oh thanks yeah,
Nathan Stephens: I like it, I like it, because
you I just had too many experiences, where I wrote
our code and I came back six months later, and I
couldn't understand what the heck I was thinking,
Nathan Stephens: Like a card that recognizes me,
you know and our mark down at least
gives you some opportunity to say,
this is what i'm thinking, this is why i'm
doing this, this is what you should expect here,
Nathan Stephens: And that that's really
valuable to just to me personally right,
like me, as a coder and then, if you layer on all
the things that are beneficial to other people,
Miguel Eersel: And I think also like
is about the different output formats,
that you can easily generally pick one of them,
Miguel Eersel: yeah me me me, can you can that's,
Miguel Eersel: What you can make
a PDF up me whatever you wish,
Nathan Stephens: yeah sure, so the
PowerPoint I showed the html but yeah
the PDF is really nice and,
Nathan Stephens: Right thanks for the thanks for
the plug yeah I see there's a
comment here about our Java,
Nathan Stephens: I kind of agree with that, one
that one's that that's real pain, hopefully,
I try to avoid our Java, when I can do the one
area Java that our time avoiding the spark spark
depends on Java and and guess what spark Java
spark is kind of difficult yeah because a job,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and
Nathan, for the slides that you shared
will I be able to share that with
the recording as well, of course,
yeah that's hosted somewhere
absolutely absolutely yeah,
Nathan Stephens: I was good, can I
can I put one thing I couldn't get
into the presentation, because
we're talking about itself but,
Nathan Stephens: All everything I showed
up on the on the presentation day that
was all file based right and there's another
type of data that we didn't get into it,
all that would be interesting to do,
Nathan Stephens: And that's machine data
so things are coming from databases right
so when when I build this presentation I
kept thinking about the data sources that
couldn't quite work it into this presentation,
Nathan Stephens: But if your
data are coming from excel,
meaning that the original source of your data,
Nathan Stephens: Actually, is excel so somebody
got into excel inputted the data, then you're
in your excel and you're not an Orlando and
that's going to be an excel for quite a while,
Nathan Stephens: But if your data source is
a database and you're pulling tables from
a database, then I think the jump
to our it's actually a lot easier,
Nathan Stephens: And I just I personally
would quite bypass excel in most cases,
and I know there's power query on stuff
right, but if i'm getting machine data
and that's not just database, but that's like
api's right or some sort of streaming feed,
Nathan Stephens: or even just curling information
from the or w get from the Web from website,
Nathan Stephens: All of those things like I
like starts leaking are personally couldn't
quite figure that in the presentation is the
the presentation was very much file
based right when you have files,
Nathan Stephens: I think figuring out where
to go or excel it's kind of like I got this
csv do I open the csv and our
excel I don't know you know
i'll default to excel right that's so much
fun, so your thing, but what is databases like,
Nathan Stephens: Thanks man,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): No
definitely a follow up question,
there was can our work directly within a database,
Nathan Stephens: Yes, the right guy,
Nathan Stephens: So yeah So if you come here to,
Nathan Stephens: Our studio and the
connections and new connection here,
Nathan Stephens: yeah, these are all
the database connections right so,
Nathan Stephens: Probably enough people use
snowflake out there, but this is a snowflake
connection and and then it will populate right
here into the connection window you browse things
so let's see if I open up my Maria
database that see if this is still active,
Nathan Stephens: Maria is like a first version of,
Nathan Stephens: postgres,
Nathan Stephens: sequel yep DEMO DEMO,
Nathan Stephens: test to test table here
was the iris dataset and i'll pull that up,
Nathan Stephens: There you go, so this this iris
data inside, so this is this is inside of the
database, or if I want to pull that data into
excel I can do that with the vdi package package,
Nathan Stephens: i'm trying to make that
we've tried to make that easy for you,
Nathan Stephens: One of my main
goals when he joins us to do this,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Now
a follow up question there Nathan was Have
you ever connected to any bank portals,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I know you've
worked with a lot of our financial customers,
Nathan Stephens: bank portals yeah we're
talking about a bank portal like thanks
keep your data really locked down we're
not getting into the blockchain or we,
Nathan Stephens: will give
me an example think portal
we work with some banks and they usually have,
Nathan Stephens: Their databases are usually
pretty traditional like a db to databases are
like that, but I guess I need more information,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And she
said, like Bank of America using an API,
Nathan Stephens: yeah well
there's lots of ways to interface
with api's through through our so again
a little bit more information, but,
Nathan Stephens: yeah the bank,
Nathan Stephens: group's the banks, the banks are,
Nathan Stephens: Those environments
are can be very restrictive right so
usually my experience with the bank it's not the
tools that are the problem it's the
policies that are the problem right so so,
Nathan Stephens: I think what i've seen a
lot of banks do is make it very difficult
to solve problems right so it's
like we can't solve this problem,
because we have all these restrictions
right, and so what ends up happening is that,
Nathan Stephens: Users kind of find a way
to get around those barriers and those
problems like maybe,
Nathan Stephens: they'll
just download the data their
desktop you know just kind of email
that around or something like stuff,
Nathan Stephens: But but but i'm not
privy data that because we don't do
that everything in our studio as
an enterprise software company
is all about board so like the securities
decision was that scary conversation comes,
Nathan Stephens: That we talked about
those all have to be answered by us,
because we're assuming that we're coming
to the front door, but my understanding is
talking to the people, to thank there's a lot
of backdoor activity going on by the employees,
Nathan Stephens: So you guys need a
little more information to help you
do a black OPS operation
there your portal API calls,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and Nathan,
one of the questions on slider was how
can we connect with you to chat about their
topics like enterprise solutions architect,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): flows,
Nathan Stephens: Just brings joy to my my
life I love to connect with any of you,
Nathan Stephens: let's see
the best way to do this,
Nathan Stephens: My email is Nathan at our
studio calm and i'm on linkedin, of course,
Nathan Stephens: used to
have Twitter but i've kind of
this is i've kind of uncoupled
from Twitter and Facebook,
Nathan Stephens: So i'd say that you
know the linkedin is probably fine
i'm also on Community darcy,com
you can find me there,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I see one
other question that came in from Rafale can we
connect are directly for any and i'm assuming this
means database dd bb and visualize real time data,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So connecting our
attendee database and visualizing real time,
Nathan Stephens: or not sure that bb
bb is another db is its database so
i'm going to assume that means the database ravel,
Nathan Stephens: Yes, if you want
to hook up like a shiny application
to a live database that isn't very common,
we have a lot of customers doing that,
and there are there are some
resources online for doing that,
Nathan Stephens: you'll have to
make sure you have permissions to
connect to that database, but
what you normally do is you
run the shiny application, either as yourself
or as a service account that has permissions to,
Nathan Stephens: to access the database and
then the tools are you're just gonna use,
Nathan Stephens: The same our tools to pull
that data and depending on the user inputs
so, for example, say i'm a user and I
want to like access my Oracle database
and I want to pull in like the
latest sales data, you know,
Nathan Stephens: I do go in
there, like put a date range
and that date range will pass through sql and
the driver and pull that data back and populate
sharing application very, very common
request very common use case for shiny,
Nathan Stephens: Okay dd add bb is database,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
Okay, I lied when I said last,
question before one other question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Anthony
Lee said i'm new to our and the docu
me from Russia so rewarding be the best
way to start getting your hands messy
is there a site with cases
to start analyzing data,
Nathan Stephens: Oh man that's gonna make me
cry okay So yes, I I hear you I see what you
see our speaks to me as well right there are
a lot of people that do that I is tell people,
Nathan Stephens: Like I will just pull up
our on the weekend and just kick around
a few ideas in my head i'll just do it
for fun, you know I want to try to see,
Nathan Stephens: If you've ever used like SAS
you can imagine porn SAS up on the weekend
I don't know any sass users, since Saturday
morning like SAS can do this thing right so
there's there is something special about our,
Nathan Stephens: And in speaking to you
that that's fantastic now last, the question
was it like getting started, how do you get
started Rachel you can answer that question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So the question is like
where to find cases to start with analyzing data,
but I do think and jake share
this in the chat as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But tidy
Tuesday I think is a great project so
every week Tuesday there's a new data set
really so then people kind of visualize
that data and then share it out on
Twitter for other people to see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I know a few other
people said try taking coursera course on our,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): there's
also a lot of great resources that
education on our studio COM to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
um but yeah if you if anyone has ideas
feel free to put them in the chat,
Nathan Stephens: I think necessity
is the mother of invention, for me, I
like I wouldn't go out, you can go to capital and
like do that competition if you want to be fun,
Nathan Stephens: But like if you have
data like that's where things get really
you know that's where really get
the motivation to do stuff so,
Nathan Stephens: If you have the
opportunity to seek out that data
and like seek out a problem that matters
that's where that's where I learned the most you
know he's like I got a challenge now it's real,
Nathan Stephens: But, are you today
is not since, yes, thank you Jesus,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just want to check
if there's any questions that I missed from the
zoom chat and a scrolling through but I
don't know if I missed anything earlier,
Nathan Stephens: or for data
science, yes, books right,
Nathan Stephens: Link for Tony Tuesday,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I think it might just
be Teddy tuesday,com i'm just
checking real quick, though,
Nathan Stephens: occasion doors to do yeah I
mean, I think I think our shoes nice job of
you know, expanding the ecosystem,
I mean there's just a lot of
pieces in the ecosystem, now that it's
really nice when I was starting our,
Nathan Stephens: wasn't going to date me guys,
but I started using our pre
Google okay so like finding,
Nathan Stephens: Information about
our back then was almost impossible,
and then, when Google did come out it wasn't
smart enough to distinguish between like are,
Nathan Stephens: The programming language
and the letter R so it's like you put are in,
there was a worthless search, you know
you'll still see the issues now with are
getting completed with reddit right like ours
something and sometimes we read it as a result,
so Google still struggles with that, but,
Nathan Stephens: Generally speaking,
yeah searching out there is going
to pretend model really great stuff,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I will also just put a,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): plug out
there for our weekly that org as well
there's a really nice job of pulling in blog
posts and different materials every week,
Nathan Stephens: there's a lot of stuff a
lot of publishing going on matt banjo banjo,
Nathan Stephens: Daniel,
Nathan Stephens: You must know
matt say how to map for me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But also up there,
I know we kind of just started off with,
Nathan Stephens: An intro so going,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
scaling spreadsheets with our,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): specific topics,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): That you'd want to
dive deeper into i'm going to
just sign Nathan up for those,
Nathan Stephens: There,
and asked if I started with the S programming
language, and the answer that is yes, I do,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
But I did a include a form there too, if you have
any feedback or things that you'd like to see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'll
try and copy that over again,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But I just want to say
thank you so much Nathan, that was awesome and I,
Nathan Stephens: I loved your honor I
really appreciate you guys I can't play,
Nathan Stephens: appreciative I am of
this like i'm I feel like this is just
wonderful opportunity, so thank you
all thank you Rachel Thank you Maria,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much,
Maria for for bringing this idea to us as
well, and thank you all for joining in,
Maria Prokofieva: Thank you, thank you, thank you,
I think that's just a thought we have so
many people doing for that virtual coffee,
Maria Prokofieva: So I think that was also an
opportunity for to connect not only like our
lovers, and like there's excel format lovers,
but also to connect continents so with that
original copies going to spread out between
Australia and Europe that's that's awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah definitely
and I just said, if people are interested,
please just email me directly, so I have very male
because meetup doesn't give me people's email,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her):
So I just put my email there,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But thank you
all so much have a great day ahead and have,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): A great evening,
Maria Prokofieva: So I have my students
here, so we are moving on to our class
and we have another half an hour of absolutely
fantastic things to do, thank you so much,